et avec nous pour ce club pierre
Jacquemin bonjour Pierre merci d'être là
freescède bonjour Nicolas fondateur et
directeur du média en ligne
fondamental.fr Steve évidemment nous a
rejoint rebonjour on va parler de la
nuque et talons en train de se fracturer
position divergente sur la stratégie
avec l'exécutif législatif en Ariège
perdu par la France insoumise face à une
dissidente socialiste alors le stage de
gauche est-il encore tenable faut-il
tout remettre à plat la France insoumise
plombe-t-elle la nuque vous nous direz
ce que vous en pensez quelles
conséquence de ces divisions dans la
bataille contre la réforme des retraites
alors que Elisabeth borne consulte les
parlementaires et les partenaires
sociaux aujourd'hui sur quoi peuvent
aboutir ces discussions on va en parler
d'abord on regarde ensemble l'actualité
dans nos régions
l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
Poitiers on retrouve Delphine Blanchard
bonjour Delphine merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous journaliste à La Nouvelle
République et Delphine vous allez nous
parler de la guerre des syndicats
agricoles qui est déclaré oui dans la
Vienne il y a une image qui a marqué les
journalistes de La Nouvelle République
présent lors de l'incident nous sommes à
la veille de la manifestation à
Sainte-Souline nous sommes donc le
vendredi 24 mars un convoi de 40
tracteurs d'agriculteurs de la
Confédération paysanne antibassine donc
passe sous le pont de la RN 10 côté
Vienne ils vont rejoindre tranquillement
en convoi escargot la commune des
Deux-Sèvres sainte Soline juste à côté
sur le pont un des journalistes de La
Nouvelle République accompagnent une
poignée de manifestants probacine et là
l'image qu'il voit est choque les
manifestants probassides les
agriculteurs probatiques crachent sur
les tracteurs au sens propre du terme si
les visions politiques ont toujours été
divergente entre syndicat agricole de
telles réactions sont heureusement rares
puisque virement à l'agribashing mais là
entre agriculteurs eux-mêmes un point de
rupture semblait donc être atteint à ce
stade là mais une étape vient d'être
franchie depuis hier dans un courriel la
FDSEA de la Vienne demande l'exclusion
pure et simple de la Confédération
paysanne des instances de la Chambre
d'Agriculture et des autres instances
représentatives compte tenues du style
de leur prise de position et des actes
qu'ils ont commis à Sainte Soline une
réclamation qui est adressée
conjointement à la préfecture de la
Vienne au département à la direction
départementale des territoires et à la
Chambre d'Agriculture donc la FDSEA
argumente en ces termes un syndicat
agricole qui appelle à une manifestation
interdite en frein 3 à 4 arrêté
préfectoraux cautionnent des
dégradations et les blessés ce n'est
plus un syndicat agricole pour rappel
dans la Vienne la Confédération paysanne
possède que deux sièges dans le collège
des chefs d'exploitation et assimiler la
Chambre d'Agriculture les élections ont
eu lieu en 2019 c'est la Coordination
rurale qui est majoritaire avec 13
sièges et la FDSEA elle en compte trois
sièges la Coordination rurale dans nos
colonnes ce matin essaye de tempérer et
de minimiser ce qu'on peut quand même
appeler selon selon moi une guerre entre
syndicats agricoles merci Delphine merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous la Une de
La Nouvelle République aujourd'hui dans
son édition de la Vienne sainte Soline
appelle à témoin lancé vous voulez nous
en dire un petit modèle film
mais une quatrième plainte vient d'être
déposée dans le cadre des de la
manifestation de Sainte-Souline
quatrième plainte manifestants blessée
donc voilà la gendarmerie appelle tous
les témoins qui auraient pu voir des
choses à venir parler de ce qu'ils ont
pu voir
aujourd'hui dans la Nouvelle République
merci beaucoup d'être Blanchard d'avoir
été avec nous merci et on parle de
sainte Soline puisque Gérald Darmanin
auditionné ce matin par le Parlement
député et sénateurs sur la question du
maintien de l'ordre notamment à Sainte
Soline est-ce qu'il faut revoir cette
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre selon
vous oui clairement oui on voit bien que
quand même depuis
quelques mois voire quelques années les
manifestations quelles qu'elles soient
de qu'elles viennent se passent pas très
bien elle se passait pas si mal que ça
quand même depuis le début du mouvement
social je pense au mouvement des
retraites qui étaient organisées par
l'intersyndical on voit que dès lors
qu'il est question de mobilisation
écologique de mobilisation local vous
les fameux zades qui sont maintenant la
cible de Monsieur Darmanin ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué donc on est plus
dans une stratégie de maintien de
l'ordre d'ailleurs les personnels de
force de l'ordre qui sont envoyés sur
place ne sont pas nécessairement formés
au maintien de l'ordre c'est dit par
beaucoup nous on a interrogé la
politique des policiers qui reprochent
justement la stratégie de Monsieur
Darmanin ou des préfets de ne pas mettre
au devant de des manifestations des
policiers des gendarmes qui sont
principalement formés justement pour
maintenir l'ordre mais il y a à la fois
la stratégie de la doc ce qu'on appelle
la doctrine de maintien de l'ordre mais
il y a aussi la stratégie qui consiste
un peu à mettre de l'huile sur le feu
c'est à dire quand vous décidez
d'interdire des modifier des
manifestations des mobilisations
forcément vous tendez la relation avec
ceux qui expriment à une revendication
et qui exprime une inquiétude ce qui est
le cas de sainte solide des manifestants
les trois organisations qui appelaient
la manifestation appelé à une
sensibilisation générale sur le sujet
qui était le
de la manière dont on pompe phréatiques
qui sont aujourd'hui dont on sait que la
denrée est absolument se fait de plus en
plus rare donc c'est ça qui est des
manifestants pacifiques est-ce que c'est
pas la crainte de manifestants radicaux
qui a poussé
parce que précisément et Monsieur
Darmanin décide d'interdire les
manifestations ça se serait sans doute
très bien passé si elle avait pas eu un
dispositif absolument colossal
exceptionnel gigantesque tel qu'elle
avait annoncé monsieur dermanent
d'ailleurs les autorités internationales
que ce soit l'ONU au niveau de l'Union
européenne et ailleurs on s'interroge
sur la disproportion aujourd'hui des
forces de l'ordre qui sont envoyées face
à des opposants politiques compare
ailleurs réprime qu'on enferme con dont
on fait des détentions arbitraires des
arrestations arbitraires il y a plus de
1200 1400 depuis le début du mouvement
social arrestation qui ont eu lieu garde
à vue 74% sont suivis de non-lieu il
faut s'interroger sur cette doctrine moi
je réponds aussi oui à votre question la
doctrine doit être
adaptée réviser les moyens aussi partir
du moment où on sait qu'il y a un risque
de déb il y a des gens qui viennent qui
ont été identifiés qui sont déjà suivis
par les services de police parce qu'ils
ont des comportements potentiellement
violents parti en ce moment-là il faut
se poser la question savoir comment on
les préviens et qu'on évite surtout d'en
arriver aux affrontements et aux risques
au risque physique et humains la
doctrine du maintien de l'Europe à la
française elle est héritée de l'après
Première Guerre mondiale et elle tente
de mettre fin à tout ce qui s'est passé
pendant un siècle et demi avant à savoir
des émeutes des morts moments où on est
obligé d'envoyer les troupes contre des
des manifestants contre des grèvistes au
tout début du siècle bon ces choses-là
elles sont elles devaient être réglées
et malheureusement l'évolution de de des
technologies l'évolution des modes de
d'action et de mobilisation fait que il
faut y réfléchir à nouveau faire en
sorte que à partir du moment où on peut
éviter ce type de rassemblement il faut
absolument les éviter parce que on le
sait les gens qui viennent à cet endroit
là c'est aussi c'est pas seulement pour
manifester en disant on n'est pas
d'accord avec les bassines c'est aussi
pour se battre et ils sont équipés pour
se battre donc à partir du moment où le
C il faut absolument prévenir les choses
qui étaient là il y a quelques minutes
disait qu'il y aura une commission
d'enquête qui souhaite une commission
d'enquête sur les violences des
manifestants envers les forces de l'or
oui bah il y a des violences de chaque
côté ça c'est la réalité on peut pas les
nier elles sont condamnables de chaque
côté que ce soit les violences faites à
l'égard des forces de l'ordre ou que ce
soit les violences faites elle les garde
des manifestants mais il est pas
possible aujourd'hui que dans une
démocratie française on se dise tiens je
vais aller manifester pour un droit pour
sensibiliser pour mon environnement et
revenir du manifestation avec un œil et
bornier un pouce en moins ou des
blessures il y a plus de 200 blessés
après sainte Soline donc deux
extrêmement graves comment c'est
possible que dans notre démocratie on ne
puisse plus aller manifester dans de
bonnes conditions et je fais le
parallèle avec la manifestations qui ont
lieu sur la réforme des retraites
Emmanuel Macron et son ministre de
l'Intérieur sont dans une stratégie
d'intimidation on a fait dans le numéro
de cette semaine de politique on a réuni
une vingtaine de personnes qui sont
victimes de violences policières c'est
pas forcément des violences physiques il
y a beaucoup d'audience physique mais
c'est aussi les violences psychologiques
les détentions arbitraires les garde à
vue les insultes les intimidations c'est
ça consiste en quoi si ce n'est intimidé
les Français qui voudraient se mobiliser
à aller dans les manifestations c'est la
première des choses la deuxième des
choses c'est la stratégie qui consiste à
interdire des manifestations il y a eu
énormément de décisions de préfet
d'interdire d'annuler des manifestations
ça a été retoqué hier par le tribunal
administratif rendez-vous compte c'est
pas la première fois que le tribunal
administratif se saisit lui-même pour
dire attention vous rendez des avis de
d'interdiction de manifestation trop
tardivement qui ne permettent pas aux
manifestants de reprendre des recours
donc là aussi il y a une stratégie quand
même qui consiste à verrouiller quand
même les oppositions et je le disais
dans quelle démocratie sommes-nous pour
un martyriser matraqué parfois les
manifestants les enfermer alors que 74%
des égards à vue aujourd'hui finissent
par des non-lieu mais c'est ça qu'il
faut interroger ça devrait nous ça
devrait nous interroger tous quand même
sur l'état de notre démocratie
aujourd'hui parce qu'il devrait
interroger c'est comment on on arrive là
c'est à dire pourquoi il y a des gens
qui se mettent à devenir ultra violent
et agresser la police et obliger la
police à être dans une un dispositif de
riposte qui et je le déplore totalement
produit des blessures ce dispositif de
riposte il doit être adapté je viens de
le dire il y a une seconde mais la
question démocratique que vous soulevez
il n'y a pas qu'une question
démocratique il y a su après une
question d'éducation et de comportement
qui est de dérive qui sont des dérives à
la fois personnels et collectives il
faut absolument aussi prévenir et plutôt
que plutôt que guérir après sur le
fonctionnement de la démocratie on est
tous d'accord pour dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses dans ce pays à à
remettre dans l'ordre et à introduire
davantage de participation citoyenne par
exemple c'est une des idées mais il y a
pas celle pas que ça
et faire en sorte que bien une fois que
des décisions ont été prises elles
soient respectées et et éviter que la
seule le seul moyen que certains jugent
nécessaire ou légitime ça soit la
violence parce que la violence c'est la
fin de la civilisation Nicolas la
première des violences elle est dans le
43 la première des violences elle est
dans non vous pouvez aller dans la
manière dont le gouvernement est sourd
revendications écologiste elle est dans
la manière dont Monsieur Darmanin si
vous dites à ce moment-là
est-il légitime donc c'est la première
des violences elle est dans la manière
dont Monsieur Darmanin parle des
écologistes comme des écouteurs ici va
sur le terrain de l'extrême droite il
reprend les termes de l'extrême droite
pour décrédibiliser une mobilisation qui
est parfaitement légitime de tout le
temps les écologistes sont pas sans
passer pour soit pour des fous soit pour
des aiates au laser et aujourd'hui on
les traite de terrorisme on en fait des
des on en fait écologistes mais c'est un
discours de Monsieur Darmanin même le
président de la République dit les gens
qui sont venus à sainte-solides sont
venus faire la guerre mais la guerre
contre qui la guerre contre qui on vient
ils viennent défendre l'idée qu'on ne
peut plus pomper les fans phréatiques
qui sont déjà aujourd'hui
par respect pour les écologistes non
violents ne les assimilez pas à ceux qui
vont casser
La Malga mais il est fait par ce
gouvernement justement géraldavin a
répondu hier à une question
sur ce sujet lors des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement c'était une
question d'un député la France insoumise
on va écouter la réponse de Gérard
darmann je n'ai aucune leçon ressort
monsieur le député de votre part d'abord
dans le lien avec les extrêmes oui
l'ultra gauche et l'ultra droite sont
les deux facettes d'extrémisme qui
touche la société française
je n'ai aucune leçon à recevoir c'est ce
gouvernement qui a dit sous notamment
généraliste identitaire et de nombreuses
milices d'extrême droite et quand le
lien entre l'islamisme et la vie
politique vraiment venante de vous ça
montre pas seul
clairement la France insoumise oui bien
sûr il y a une posture politique qui
consiste pour pour lui mais pas que pour
lui pour une partie de la classe
politique à considérer la France
insoumise comme la principale force
d'opposition et donc à être en attaque
si ou en réplique systématique face aux
parties de Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc pour
Gérald Darmanin c'est une posture qui
est assez facile assez simple et ça lui
permet d'être dans un discours assez
récurrent contre l'extrême gauche et
aussi de se positionner lui et on l'a
entendu et vous avez fait référence à
ces dernières déclarations dans un
discours une posture de plus en plus à
droite alors il semble qu'il fasse le
Paris que pour 2027 il y ait une
constitution sur la scène politique
française et dans l'opinion d'un clivage
droite-gauche en essayant de tenter
peut-être
d'être celui qui incarnera l'aile droite
non seulement de la macronie mais aussi
de l'opinion française donc ça c'est
c'est sa stratégie politique est-ce que
ça va se réaliser c'est pas du tout sûr
parce que est-ce que les Français
voilà vont revenir à l'ancien clivage
bon non c'est rien mais en tout cas
c'est le pari qu'il tente et qu'il tente
de façon beaucoup plus appuyé ces
derniers jours monsieur dermanin a
choisi son adversaire voir son ennemi et
pardon mais je n'ai pas entendu monsieur
Darmanin s'offusquer s'indigner du de
des faits ou en tout cas des violences
de l'extrême droite quand il s'est agit
d'aller brûler la maison du maire de
Saint-Brevin qui voulait accueillir des
exilés sur son territoire je n'ai pas
entendu monsieur Darmanin quand il
s'était agit des militants d'extrême
droite qui ont brûlé la porte d'entrée
du de la mairie de de Bordeaux je n'ai
pas entendu monsieur Darmanin il y a
d'ailleurs un très bon papier une très
belle enquête aujourd'hui dans
Libération qui fait la Une de Libération
sur les violences d'extrême droite qui
cible 90 journalistes politiques
syndicat avocat et qui veulent en
découdre avec ces gens-là par ceux qui
se réduisent à la société française
monsieur dammarlin a fait le choix d'un
combat politique contre la nupes qui
serait l'ennemi politique numéro 1 et
aujourd'hui en banalisant justement
cette violence et le discours d'extrême
droite qui le reprend à son compte
pardon mais quand il va dans le JDD ce
weekend pour dire aujourd'hui ce sont il
y a des éco terroristes et c'est eux le
danger il fait un choix politique il
fait un choix politique de banalisation
de ce qu'est la véritable violence qui
est la violence d'extrême droite c'est
la première des menaces aujourd'hui le
terrorisme il parle de terrorisme
d'extrême gauche mais c'est le
terrorisme d'extrême droite aujourd'hui
la première des violences et il n'en
fait pas son combat c'est bien ça qu'on
lui reproche aujourd'hui il n'a pas fait
son combat notamment du rassemblement
national
comment dire on est dans dans des débats
depuis le début de la législature ou le
le les insoumis notamment au sein de la
nupette font le spectacle à l'Assemblée
nationale et attire toutes les les
critiques possibilités imaginables de
gouvernement et la droite pendant ce
temps-là on le voit on voit notamment
dans les sondages la seule force
politique qui en profite c'est à ce
moment national et qui est très peu
attaqué elle en profite d'autant plus
donc il y a une situation vous avez
raison de le souligner il y a une
situation qui est assez paradoxale entre
d'un côté une UPS qui finalement a un
influence et un gain et un pouvoir
politique qui est très limité et de
l'autre côté un rassemblement national
qui qui n'a pas davantage mais qui lui
anti-profit
de la nuit passe justement puisque si en
ce moment on a l'impression que ça
craque un peu de partout
diviser dernier épisode dernier épisode
en date hier une délégation de députés
et de sénateurs de gauche avec prévu de
ce s'inviter l'initiative avait été
lancé la semaine dernière par les
parlementaires communistes qui avaient
proposé à tous les élus opposés à la
réforme des retraites de ce joindre à
eux l'idée c'était de remettre en main
propre une lettre à Emmanuel Macron pour
lui demander de retirer sa réforme hier
les communistes sont attendus attendus
les autres ne sont jamais venus à part
le député Bertrand pencher président du
groupe liberté territoire à l'Assemblée
nationale en revanche pas de socialiste
pas d'écologie pas d'insoumis qui était
pourtant espéré attendu ce qui est ce
qui était là ils ont quand même fait
cette marche qu'elle est de la Concorde
à l'Élysée ça avait un petit air de
marche de l'empereur du coup peu de
monde dans le cortège et quelques
épreuves à passer notamment les preuves
des caméras à écouter
nous avons voulu ce front unique après
moi je vous invite à aller poser la
question à celles et ceux qui ne sont
pas là aujourd'hui si on est là
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on a un pays
qui est encore en ébullition parce que
le gouvernement et le président de la
République n'entendent pas retirer cette
réforme les élus communistes ont été
reçus à l'Élysée par le directeur de
cabinet du président Patrick strauda ils
ont pu lui remettre la fameuse lettre et
échanger avec lui pendant une petite
demi-heure et mes socialistes ne se sont
pas rendus à cette marche ils avaient
d'autres problèmes à traiter un peu la
tête ailleurs elle a fait Martine Froget
occupe les esprits pour rappel une
élection législative partielle a eu lieu
le week-end dernier en Ariège en finale
du scrutin on retrouvait d'un côté une
dissidente socialiste Martine Froget de
l'Aude Bénédicte Bénédicte taurine
député insoumise sortante candidate de
la nupes c'est la première qu'il a
emporté avec un peu plus de 60% des voix
la question est de se voir elle de
savoir maintenant dans quel groupe va
siéger Martin Froget et hier la chef du
groupe insoumis à l'Assemblée nationale
lui a déclaré sa flamme
pour que une députée qui a fait battre
une députée de l'intergroupe de la new
Pesse siège vers le groupe socialiste et
je suis sûr que beaucoup des socialistes
seront d'accord avec moi sur cette
question le problème c'est que ce ne
sont pas les insoumis qui décident si
oui ou non Martin Froget va siéger dans
le groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale mais bien les députés
socialistes eux-mêmes rappellent
fraternel de camarades à camarades de la
sénatrice socialiste Marie-Pierre
delagontrie c'était sur Twitter bah en
fait c'est pas toi qui décide voilà
c'est le dit à Mathilde panneau ouais
ambiance on va y revenir et pendant ce
temps là Olivier Faure et Marine
tondeuse
et la patronne des écologistes ont
accepté l'invitation d'Elizabeth borne
la première ministre on en parlait tout
à l'heure à entamer lundi une série de
consultations avec les groupes
parlementaires pour dit-elle tenter
d'apaiser le pays la double rencontre
donc déroulée hier après-midi Olivier
fort et Marine tondeuillier ont tous
deux demandaient le retrait de la
réforme des retraites
sur les retraites on a été très très
rapide on lui a dit qu'il n'y aurait pas
de paix sans retrait et quand je dis ça
c'est pas une menace de ma part ce sont
les faits c'est la terre esprit du pays
je pense que on est dans une impasse et
que tant que il n'y aura pas de retrait
sur cette mesure des 64 ans on ne
passera pas à autre chose ni nous ni les
autres pas de paix sans retrait de la
réforme des retraites à la nupestre tout
le monde est d'accord sur le fond en
revanche la méthode à adopter face au
gouvernement fait débat les insoumis ont
eux refusé de rencontrer Elisabeth
borgne il considère qu'il s'agit d'une
diversion politique agité par l'exécutif
pour calmer la colère sociale ouais on
voit division leur passion le fond
puisque tout le monde est contre la
réforme mais sur la stratégie à adopter
est-ce que la nuque est en train
d'exploser
je pense qu'il faut faire le distinguer
entre deux choses il y a ce qu'est la
muppesse réellement la nuit Pesse c'est
la construction d'une
d'un groupe politique d'un d'une
majorité d'idées à gauche qui s'est
constitué dans le cadre de législatives
et qui fonctionne plutôt bien à
l'Assemblée nationale hier soir s'est
réuni l'intergroupe justement de la nups
à l'Assemblée nationale je sais qu'il y
a des divergences il y a des discussions
mais globalement la Réunion en sort a
d'ailleurs ils ont sorti un communiqué
en fin de réunion hier soir tard où ils
disent grosso modo nous allons continuer
à travailler ensemble nous continuons de
manière unitaire ce combat contre la
réforme des retraites on a d'autres
échéances à venir qui sont qui sont
évidemment actées dans le cadre de cette
interview et puis il y a la vie des
parties en dehors chacun a sa vie
effectivement le Parti communiste tente
de faire cavalier seul les écologistes
sont pas dans les sur les routes de
France avec leur convention je sais plus
quel est le terme utilisé mais où ils
vont voir il y a les Français sur la
question de l'écologie les socialistes
bon elles sont divisés sur une question
stratégique c'est une UPS ou pas UPS
avec l'échec de la stratégie d'Olivier
fort en tout cas l'échec en tout cas la
victoire
grâce à la droite et à l'extrême droite
de de la candidate dissidente socialiste
donc il y a la vie des partis politiques
à gauche qui est normal ce qui est
logique et puis à la vie de la nupège je
pense qu'il y a une volonté je crois
assez clair affichée et déterminé des
différentes organisations politiques
soit du PC de la France insoumise du
Parti socialiste et les écologistes à
faire vivre cette espace politique
au-delà justement de l'Inter groupe de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas simple
c'est certain parce que c'est des
traditions c'est les sensibilités
différentes vous voyez dans le cadre de
la future élection européenne qu'il y a
des stratégies divergentes mais la
gauche a-t-elle autre solution que de
converger vers une majorité et donc de
décider de faire ensemble si ce n'est si
elle ne le fait pas je vois pas très
bien comme moi elle peut un jour espérer
reprendre le pouvoir
les différences ne sont pas trop
nombreuses Nicolas bien sûr et on va
voir au fil des semaines qu'elles vont
s'affirmer de plus en plus pourquoi
d'une part vous l'avez évoqué il y a les
européennes qui arrivent chaque partie
va y aller tout seul il y a pas un label
nupes aux européennes on l'appelle écolo
un label p
les premiers à dire que voilà ils
allaient présenter leur liste c'est une
élection les européennes qui leur
réussit plutôt bien donc ils auraient
tort de se priver de de cette exposition
et de se débat politique ensuite on le
voit la nups dans le cas de la réforme
des retraites il se passe quand même
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'est que
il disait d'un côté vous avez un
mouvement social qui est très fort qui
est très soutenu par la population et de
l'autre côté vous avez des forces
politiques qui sont supposées être en
phase mais qui n'en tirent aucun profit
politique aucun bénéficiaire personne
parmi la nups qui peut aujourd'hui
revendiquer ou incarner le le gain
social politique et social de la réforme
des retraites en disant bah regardez
c'est moi qui suis la personne
représentative politiquement et pas
syndicalement de cet ensemble de
manifestants qui sont unis et assez
forts contre la réforme des retraites
mais ça ça ne s'est pas produit pourquoi
parce que ils sont tous très divisés ils
ont des stratégies du coup qui essaient
de comment on va faire pour quand même
apparaître comme étant bénéficiaire de
ce mouvement social donc chacun va
essayer de se recréer un peu plus
d'espace politique alors est-ce qu'on
rencontrait ladybug un jour c'est non le
lendemain c'est oui pour les socialistes
et les écologistes est-ce qu'on y va pas
est-ce qu'on on reste de quoi on discute
bon ils sont tous dans dans la recherche
de leur singularité et vous faisiez
référence aux parties bah le Parti
communiste commence à dire par la voix
de Fabien Roussel peut-être qu'il faut
que la nups est dépassée qu'il faut
chercher autre chose jusqu'à Bernard
Cazeneuve on imagine très très mal que
il puisse y avoir un dialogue
constructif entre Bernard Cazeneuve et
les insoumis par exemple puisque il se
déteste cordialement pour des raisons de
forme et de fonds et donc on va on va
voir des des initiatives au fur et à
mesure que les semaines vont passer pour
tenter à gauche si possible de se
retrouver des marges de manoeuvre de
retrouver de l'oxygène indépendamment
les uns des autres est-ce que la
législative en arrière où on le rappelle
une dissidente socialiste abattue la
députée sortante la France finalement a
mis en lumière les plaies au sein de la
nuque je pense que l'Ariège n'est pas
n'est pas la France en tout cas la
cartographie
l'électorat de l'Ariège les
circonstances politiques en Ariège où il
y a une forte présence quand même de
Carole deliga de
du des radicaux enfin je veux dire le
contexte de l'arrière je n'ai pas perdu
le contexte de la d'accord elle a perdu
comment c'était le même contexte on peut
se dire que la perd du coup ce que je
veux dire c'est
ça signifie ça n'est pas significatif ça
vaut avertissement sans doute mais ça
n'est pas significatif ce que je crois
c'est qu'il y a effectivement de gauche
il y a eu des modules échanger
de chaque côté et il y a une très bonne
tribune d'ailleurs du président du
conseil général du Conseil départemental
pardon de la Seine-Saint-Denis
aujourd'hui dans le phyton post qui
remet les choses au clair il faut que
ces deux gauches là arrête de se taper
dessus c'est sûr que si la gauche veut
un jour reprendre le pouvoir il va
falloir qu'elle trouve les voisines de
rediscuter et de renouer et de de
d'avancer ensemble là il y a deux choses
il y a un la France insoumise qui est
clairement majoritaire aujourd'hui à
gauche qui est un peu la colonne
vertébrale de la gauche ça a été tranché
au moment de législatives qui elle est
sûre de son choix beaucoup trop sûr de
ses choix sur le bruit la fureur et qui
ne recule devant rien et qui ne veut pas
faire ni son mea culpa sur la question
de la démocratie mis sur mes lac ou pas
sur la question de sa stratégie
parlementaire et de l'autre côté il y a
la gauche qui mais des bâtons dans les
roues de ce qu'est la nupesque et la
bande de Monsieur Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol Anne Hidalgo Carole Delga
monsieur Cazeneuve d'une partie et eux
ils ont un peu la nostalgie d'un Parti
socialiste hégémonique et bah non il
faut qu'il fasse le constat comme l'a
fait avec courage Olivier Faure se dire
que le Parti socialiste n'est plus la
colonne vertébrale telle qu'elle a été
pendant un demi-siècle dans le siècle
passé mais que il faut savoir rediscuter
et donc trouver des composés des voies
de compromis ces deux gauches là doivent
faire leur introspection et leur propre
mais à coupa et leur critique et parce
que clairement local ou c'est le signe
qui a un affaiblissement de la France
insoumise je pense encore une fois que
c'est local que ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas vocation à traduire en tout cas des
conclusions qui seraient un peu trop
hâtives maintenant je pense que ça vaut
avertissement certainement parce que
elle avait elle a été lu une première
fois madame bénédictine donc ça veut
dire qu'elle avait obtenu majorité si
cette fois-ci elle n'a pas obtenu une
majorité ça pose question encore une
fois ça se fait dans un contexte où on
sait que Madame Frugier a été élu par
les voies de la droite
de la macronie et de l'extrême droite
enfin je viens le résultat est clair
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un front
anti-up qui dessine et je pense que
c'est plus ça qui doivent valoir alerte
du côté de la nupesse sur la
constitution alimentée par Monsieur
Darmanin monsieur Macron une partie de
la gauche sur ce qui est la nups qui
serait aujourd'hui devenu anti
républicaine et je pense que là-dessus
il y a matière à travailler à
s'interroger mais de chaque côté de
toute part quoi je pense que chacun a
une part de responsabilité sur la raison
pour laquelle aujourd'hui la lupesse est
devenue l'ennemi public si ce n'est
l'ennemis politiques numéro 1 on
continue qui est en train de se créer je
suis pas totalement convaincu alors
effectivement on peut faire le constat
que
la façon dont la France insoumise
spécifiquement se comporte à l'Assemblée
nationale
hérissent parti des électeurs de gauche
c'est d'ailleurs on a vu des l'année
dernière dans les sondages qui portaient
sur les attentes des électeurs de gauche
qui avait une demande quand même de
travail de compromis de négociation y
compris chez les insoumis et on a
constaté effectivement que c'était pas
le cas qui avait des postures qui
l'emportaient et la volonté souvent de
faire le spectacle donc ça ça éloigne
une partie de l'électorat de gauche des
insoumis mécaniquement mais ça explique
vraiment la défaite de la France
insoumise le week-end dernier donc oui
il y a sans doute une réflexion sur la
stratégie politique à mener chez les
insoumis qui qui fasse un jour la mesure
de des gains et des pertes politiques au
terme de cette exposition assez
exceptionnelle qu'ils ont à l'assemblée
qui ont jamais eu jusque-là
sur la bataille du coup les conséquences
sur la bataille contre la réforme des
retraites parce qu'on voit l'Inter
syndicale reçu ce matin qui s'affiche
unit et qui insiste pour montrer qu'il
est et puis là vous avez la gauche si
vous la rappelez certains vont à
Matignon d'autres marches devant
l'Élysée donc son Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que du coup tout
ça ça affaiblit pas la gauche dans cette
bataille
on voit bien qu'effectivement il y a une
question stratégique majeure qui qui se
joue à la fois du côté de
l'intersyndicale et du côté de la des
forces politiques mais je mets presque
de côté les questions des forces places
parce que le temps aujourd'hui est venu
à la mobilisation sociale au mouvement
social et donc à la stratégie de
l'intersyndicale on publie ce matin une
tribune qui va sans doute faire
râler une partie de l'Inter syndicale
mais j'ai souhaité la publier sur le
site de politique parce que elle met les
syndicalistes sans doute les plus
combatifs les plus engagés dans la lutte
depuis le mois de janvier avec ceux qui
ont fait le plus de temps de grève
depuis ces trois derniers mois c'est
beaucoup des gens qui viennent des
raffineries des éboueurs voilà ça fait
trois mois qui sont engagés dans la
lutte et dans les dans les grèves et qui
s'associe à des intellectuels avec un
Yernaux avec Edward Louis avec Robert
Guédigian et d'autres qui s'associent
pour alerter sur la stratégie de l'Inter
syndical qui tant à faire un peu du
surplace c'est-à-dire que à ne pas
vouloir aller plus loin et ne pas dire
les mots tels que les syndicalistes qui
plus de 350 tribune ne pas vouloir dire
les mots qui fâchent c'est à dire grève
générale appel à des des durcissement
justement et donc à ne pas aller
négocier avec Elisabeth borne pour pour
obtenir je ne sais quoi dans le cadre
d'une médiation voilà cette tribune
alerte sur cette stratégie du surplace
de l'intersyndicale je la trouve
intéressante je suis pas d'accord avec
tout parce que je la trouve assez
injuste parfois sur la stratégie dans un
certain nombre de personnes et de
leaders syndicale notamment Sophie Binet
la nouvelle patronne de la CGT qui a dit
clairement on va au rendez-vous avec
Elizabeth borne mais on y va pas pour
obtenir une médiation on y va pour
obtenir le retrait donc je trouve que
clairement les choses sont tout à fait
éclair et établies donc oui je pense
qu'il y a un sujet quand même de la
stratégie de l'intersyndicale même si
l'unité a été sa force
elle a aussi été le fruit de compromis
et on sait que les compromis ne mènent
pas toujours à des Bata à des à des à
une radicalisation je le dis comme ça de
la mobilisation ce qui serait peut-être
nécessaire aujourd'hui c'est à dire
effectivement des appels à la grève
générale mais comme le disait
syndicalisme
à la grève jamais jamais d'ailleurs tout
le monde d'ailleurs vous connaissez le
Parker de même de Monsieur Martinez ou
de Monsieur Laurent Berger qui est de
dire il s'agit pas de dire on veut la
grève générale et ils ont raison ça se
décrète pas la grève générale c'est à
l'échelle des entreprises à bloquer le
pays ça c'est pas produit donc ils n'ont
aucune chance de de réussir une grève
générale déjà si vous réussissez pas le
premier la première étape comment
réussir la seconde donc cette volonté de
radicalisation que que vous relayez
c'est une volonté de durcissement mais
mais qui peut produire qu'à soit des
débordements soit un échec politique
donc c'est on peut comprendre qu'il y
ait
une forme de de déception sur la
stratégie de l'intersyncal puisque
effectivement la réforme de retraite
n'est toujours pas retirée mais en même
temps
allez à la limite de ce qui est
l'expression syndicale et puis dire un
jour ah bah c'est pas de notre faute si
on l'a dépassé est-ce que c'est
responsable moi je me pose la question
donc peut-être qu'il y a des
imperfections dans la démocratie on a
parlé tout à l'heure et qui a sans doute
des choses à améliorer c'est indubitable
mais le le toutes les discours qui vont
essayer de pousser les manifestants dans
leur limite physique c'est des discours
qui sont dangereux et l'Inter syndicale
a très prudemment et et très finement
éviter d'aller jusque là y compris
flipman
la question c'est comment les gens se
font entendre les gens qui sont
mobilisés qui ont perdu non non pardon
non non les gens sont revenus les gens
ça fait trois mois qui sont mobilisés
qui sont en grève qu'ils ont perdu un
salaire ils ont l'impression de ne pas
être entendu donc à quel moment dans
l'histoire depuis que Emmanuel Macron a
été élu la les opposants à la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron ont été entendus c'est
ça qui il faut repenser et hélas ça a
été dans des moments où il y a eu
l'effet de violence et c'est ça qui est
problématique c'est qu'on ne se fait
entendre qu'à partir du moment où il y a
de la violence c'est ça qui est
problématique mais c'est la seule c'est
l'impasse qui aujourd'hui mais j'y crois
pas du tout et ben vous viendra débattre
la semaine prochaine sur ce fait merci à
tous les deux regarde ce qu'elle a une
de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
c'est lubreton Bordeaux
Paris à vous le savez voter le week-end
dernier pour la fin des trottinettes en
libre-service Bordeaux métropole ne
compte pas en faire de même c'est elle a
une de Sud-Ouest aujourd'hui qui nous
dit que les Bordelais tiennent à leur
trottinette en libre-service la mairie
envisage pas d'interdire ses engins
d'autant plus qu'ils font déjà l'objet
d'un encadrement très strict seulement
deux opérateurs sont autorisés à
commercialiser leur flotte des règles
précises existent notamment en matière
de stationnement dans la métropole à
Nantes c'est le moment de rêver oui
raison plus grand c'est le second vous
avez d'un autre club de foot le PSG mais
il s'applique aujourd'hui
on commence un peu compliqué mais le
slogan s'applique aujourd'hui au nantais
qui accueille ce soir l'Olympique
Lyonnais en demi-finale de la Coupe de
France Presse Océan titre sur ce match
la stade de la Beaujoire sera plein à
craquer les Nantais rêvent de retourner
au Stade de France pour disputer une
nouvelle finale on rappelle que les
Nantais sont les tenants du titre merci
pu être Marseille mais c'est pas passé
du PSG comme ça c'est réglé
[Musique]